(typing)
- Hey!
Okay, so I got two different types of tile
that we can choose from,
and I think this one's nice.
It's a little bit more simple.
And then this--
- No, I told you, you do the tiles.
I don't care.
I don't have an opinion and
I have to get this pitch done
for Adventure Baby.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- Please, please, please, please.
Take this.
Take this away.
- Alright, I'll figure it out.
- Thank you.
- I'm sorry.
(keyboard clacking)
Jason?
- What?
- Have you been using my iPad?
- Your iPad?
- Oh, no.
You've been going to porn sites.
- No, no I haven't.
- Do not masturbate with my iPad, Jason.
And you're busy.
Oh, yeah, you're so busy.
You're busy masturbating with my iPad.
That's how busy you are.
- The internet is so fast on there.
I'm sorry.
- Jason, why are you
masturbating anyway, huh?
Hello, I'm open for business.
- Yeah.
- And you look great. I just...
You know, we've been getting
along so well lately.
I don't want to ruin the friendship.
(cymbal tapping)
- Hey.
- (Woman) Hey there.
- Oooo! Whoa! Whoa, look at that.
Lookin' good. That's the
old...that's the old nighty.
That's the little action nighty.
- (Woman) Yes.
- Yep.
- We can do it tonight.
- You know what? I really, I really...
I would love to, it's just...
Can I be honest?
- Of course. What?
- You won't tell anyone?
- Who am I gonna tell?
- Okay. I've just been like...
I'm really bumming out
about my penis lately.
- What?
- It's really small.
- No it's not. It really isn't.
- No it's...it's...
- It's fine.
- I stand in the mirror and
I'm like, what's going on?
It's so small.
It's just not...and it's not fun.
It's not fun for me having a small penis.
It's like, it's like
having someone in your band
that isn't good.
You know? It's like...
It just ruins all of it.
- Have you been watching too much porn?
- I have been watching a lot of porn.
- How much would you say
you've been masterbating?
- Like three or four everyday.
Is that a lot?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. That is a lot.
- That's a lot.
- Well hey, got no problem in that area.
Lot of guys have problems.
Not me.
- Dad! It's me.
Hello!
Jason can you come in here please?
I don't under...
- (Jason) What?!
- Can you come in here
and help with the...?
I don't under...
- (Jason) The what?
- With the Facetime on the I...
I don't understand if it's work...
Dad, hi!
- I can hear you but I can't see you.
Where are you?
- (Jason) Hold on.
- Okay look for the camera guys.
- Hold on.
- I see...hi.
- Hi.
- I see you. That...
- Is that you live?
I mean it's not a video?
This is really you now, live?
- Yes! You're talking to me right now.
What kind of ques...
What are you...
Can you hear me?
- You know, we went to a party today
and we really had a great time.
- Jason we thought about you.
There was a clown. He was fabulous
but you would have been better.
- Yeah, you know, maybe Jason
you should think about doing some clowning
at some parties for kids.
You know, you've given
this comedy thing a shot
but let's get real, it's not...
I don't think it's really
working out for you.
Maybe you should try clowning.
- I, I don't want
to be a party clown Joe.
- No he's...
I don't want to be.
- Stop, stop, stop.
That's not what I want
to do with my life. So...
- Just stop. Just stop.
Dad he's not gonna be a clown alright?
Just enough with the clown?
- I'm not a clown.
- He doesn't...he doesn't even know how
to make the balloon animals.
There's like...
No, he's not a clown.
- It's not the same thing.
A stand up is not the
same thing as a clown.
I know that you think that it is.
- Wait, just stop. J,
J. Just stop, just stop.
- Are you sure this is you live?
We're talking live?
Real time?
(jazz music)
- (Jason) Oh my god.
Okay. Okay here we go.
You ready?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Are you ready?
- Yeah!
- Okay.
- Okay, Jason...
- (Jason) Oh god that's it.
- You're like...
- (Jason) Oh god that's good. Oh wow.
- What?
- (Jason) Ugh!
- What?!
- Ugh! Oooo god! Whooo!
Oh my god baby! Oh my
god that's good! Whoo!
Oh my god.
- That was it?
- You're so good. Is that not good?
- No that wasn't good.
That was weird and aweful.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
You know what it is?
You are so hot.
It's, it's...
You know what it is?
It's a compliment.
You're so, you're so hot.
You know what?
You're the real thing
and no more porn for me.
- Alright well...
I guess thanks for the compliment.
- You're welcome.
I love you.
- Yeah...
I'm gonna just...I'm
gonna go to the bathroom.
- Okay.
Oh you know what I would love right now?
Doritos.
- (Gasp) I think I hear her.
Listen Mom, I'm gonna go get her.
- Go, go ahead!
Go get the baby, we want to see her!
- So just don't disconnect
cause I don't want to go
through that again okay?
(moans)
- What's going on?
- I don't know.
What...what is that?
What are we seeing?
(screams)
- (Woman) Yes! Yes!
- (Gasp) Oh my god!
- No wonder he doesn't want to get a job!
He sits around the house
jerking off all day!
- Oh my god!
Oh no!
- (Woman) Yes!
Oh god, oh god!
- J?
(knocks)
- Are you in there?
Do you have my I-pad?
- Oh my god.
- Mom?
Are you here?
Got disconnected.
Come here Char.
(band music)